If you happen to run into your ideal employer or business partner in an elevator...
...or anywhere else for that matter, you'll have about 30 seconds or less to wow them.
Here's how to do it.
You will need: skills or ideas, a list of descriptive phrases,...
...a description of your qualifications and practice.
Optional: a mirror.
Step 1: Brainstorm a list of phrases that describe you...
...and cross off any cliches or catchphrases.
Keep only the most unique and honest statements.
Step 2: Craft a description of qualifications that you can share in 30 seconds or less.
Write the pitch like you speak.
This will make it easier to deliver and make it sound more authentic.
Step 3: Practice your pitch on friends and family.
Ask for feedback and adjust your pitch.
It will become natural by doing it over and over.
Use a mirror to pitch yourself.
If you can't look yourself in the eye, how can you engage someone else?
Step 4: Make your pitch about the needs of your listener.
Talk about the problems facing their industry that you are uniquely positioned to solve.
Step 5: Describe your value in solving these problems.
Step 6: Allow room for dialog.
Most people don't like to be talked at, so be conversational and show an interest in them.
Step 7: Ask for something.
A business card, a phone call or permission to send your resume.
The point of your pitch is to break the ice and generate interest...
...but you need to ask for the next step.
Did you know?
As of 2009, the Taipei Financial Center in Taiwan...
...featured the world's fastest elevator, running at a top speed of 39 miles per hour.